all right let us waste no time because
we have such an agenda here at the start
of today's show updated numbers for
Democrats and Republicans in the House
and Senate in what now are midterm
elections that are just about six weeks
away numbers continue to improve for
Democrats in both the House and Senate
although Democrats are still not favored
to win in the house let's look at the
numbers in the 538 forecast for the
Senate 2022
it is now a 71 chance that Democrats
will win and only a 29 chance that
Republicans will win the most likely
outcomes are Democrats maintaining a
50-50 majority because Kamala Harris
would be the tie-breaking vote Or
democrats having a 51-49 Advantage the
way that these numbers have changed over
the last several months is directly in
the favor of Democrats as you can see if
you're looking at the screen at the
beginning of June Democrats had about a
40 percent chance of holding the Senate
that has climbed steadily to a new high
of 71 now things that happen 29 of the
sorry things that are 29 likely to
happen
happened 29 out of every hundred times
so that doesn't mean that there is any
guarantee here but right now the most
mathematically likely scenario is
Democrats holding the Senate either 50
50 or 51 to 49. now over in the house
the numbers are not looking as good for
Democrats but the numbers are closing in
on basically a two to one likelihood of
Republicans taking the house which is
far worse for Republicans than it has
been at any previous point during this
election cycle
28 chance for Democrats and again if we
look at how those numbers have shifted
over time you will see that what was at
one point a 14 chance for Democrats at
one point a 12 percent chance for
Democrats has now surged all the way up
to a 28 chance again the most likely
outcome is still that Republicans will
take control of the house but the
likelihood of that has declined steadily
for a period of June July August three
and a half months three and a half
months as we've said before
if at this same rate the numbers
continue to improve for Democrats by
election day it would be close to 50 50.
we don't know that that's going to
happen but that's the way the numbers
look today and the important thing is
everyone must vote do not concede any
seat fight for everything let's talk
about vpn's virtual private networks
even if you're using incognito mode on
your browser if you're not using a VPN
everything you do online can be recorded
by your internet provider and that is
permanent because they're selling it
search engines social media companies
are also tracking your every move you
only need one thing to protect yourself
from all of it private internet access
one of our sponsors it's a VPN it's
simple you take a moment and you
download it you turn it on and you're
protected and you stay protected and
that's it vpns can also keep your
connection secure from hackers important
every time you check your bank account
or 401k or pension otherwise it can all
be out in the open private internet
access never records or stores user data
they've even proven this policy multiple
times in court their software is open
source to show that there's no data
being logged this transparency is why
private internet access is the VPN I use
and my audience gets 82 percent off so
you can stay protected for Just Two
Dollars and 11 cents a month plus you'll
get three months free go to
privateinternetaccess.com Pacman the
link is down below